[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Jennifer Aaker.
I'm a behavioral scientist who
spent my career, studying,
what actually creates happiness and
life versus what we think.
>> I'm Naomi Bagdonas.
I'm a corporate strategist who spent my
career straddling the worlds of business
and improv comedy,
which was a wide straddle.
I'm Connor Diemand-Yauma,
a social entrepreneur and
CEO who spent my career building vibrant,
productive, and humorous cultures.
>> Together we teach a class called Humor,
Serious Business,
about the power of humor and leadership.
It turns out humor is a teachable skill,
and
it's one of the most under
appreciated assets at work.
>> Laughing changes the chemistry of
our brains making us more creative,
bonded and resilient.
Humor is an elixir for trust and
an antidote to arrogance, especially for
today's leaders.
>> But here's the problem.
We fallen off a humor cliff and
global study over a million people
were asked a really simple question.
Did you smile or laugh the, yesterday?
Now, as kids, we laugh all the time.
And then, right when we enter
the workforce, we stop laughing.
And we don't start laughing
again until we retire.
>> Which is why it's time to
start taking humor seriously.
Here are five key takeaways from our
course to help you climb back up the humor
cliff, add more humor at work and
in your life.
[MUSIC]
>> Our research reveals that there
are four broad humor styles and
most people naturally fall into one or
two of them.
First is the stand up.
Stand ups are bold natural entertainers
unafraid to ruffle a few feathers for
a laugh.
Next is the sweetheart.
Sweethearts are earnest, understated and
tend to use humor that lightens the mood.
Snipers are edgy, sarcastic, nuanced and
masters of the unexpected dig.
Finally, there's the magnet.
Magnets are expressive, charismatic and
not afraid to be silly.
Once you know your style,
you can start applying a few simple
techniques from the world of comedy.
[MUSIC]
>> To have more humor, start by making
simple observations throughout the day of
things you find interesting,
odd, or amusing.
Since working from home,
I only calm the front part of my hair.
Or I get really excited when people
cancel plans, isn't that the best?
Or I wish there were a mute
button in real life.
Now remember that this isn't
about becoming a comedian,
it's about looking at
the world in a different way.
Our brains are wired to find
what we set out to look for.
So start looking for humor.
[MUSIC]
>> At work, it's easy to be transactional,
but small shifts can move us
from transactional to human.
As small as adding a light hearted line
at the end of your LinkedIn bio, or
kicking off a meeting with
your favorite TED lasso clip.
Are you going to sign off
your emails with best?
Instead, try something like yours,
heavily caffeinated or
let's never speak of this again.
Or sometimes, I'm the best.
Sometimes you just gotta let people know.
[MUSIC]
>> Humor can be risky risky.
Here are a few things we tell our
students about how to de risk your humor.
First, don't ask will
this make me sound funny?
Instead, ask how will this
make other people feel?
Which also means never punching down, that
is, making fun of someone of lower status.
And be sure to check your distance.
How close are you personally to
what you're making light of?
I can make fun of my mother but
not Jennifer's mother who by the way,
I hear is a saint.
>> She is a saint, thank you.
>> A lovely woman.
[MUSIC]
>> It's easy to believe that if you take
your life or your mission seriously,
the presence of humor
betrays that mission.
[MUSIC]
As leaders of all stripes, from
secretary of State Madeleine Albright to
NBA All Star Stephen Curry to
CEO Sara Blakely, tell a different story.
That we can do serious things without
taking ourselves too seriously.
And in fact, often we can do them better.
>> Our hope is that you start climbing
back up the humor Cliff get to
know your humor style.
Mind your life for truth.
Make small shifts from
transactional to human.
Practice safe sets and
make the choice to navigate your
life on the precipice of a smile.
In other words,
start taking humor seriously.
>> Seriously.
[LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
I love it.
>> [LAUGH]